good morning John I just slept for four
days and I'm feeling pretty good I
suggest you try it sometime here's how
it works you lay down and you don't get
up for four days well most people aren't
like me they they literally feel as if
they have to get out of bed sometimes
and no I don't feel that especially not
after VidCon a time in which I did not
sleep at all and probably caused a
global epidemic with whatever disease
that I was carrying in my body while I
hugged all those hugs and shook all of
those hands big significant apology big
one I hope you don't die John to be
totally honest I kind of felt like all
of YouTube was going to hate us after
VidCon either they were gonna be one of
the hundreds of thousands of people who
were sick of hearing about it and
weren't able to come or because I orb
you or we did something that was so
epically failed that no one would ever
forgive us and at this point no one
would be saying anything about VidCon
except for how lame it was and how
horrible the vlogbrothers are but here
we are after VidCon and I think I think
it's safe to say that no one no one
seems to hate us in fact a lot of people
seem to like us more we are in the 300
thousand subscriber Club we are in the
top 100 most subscribed of all time on
YouTube which you know has been a long
time coming and I have a play pinball
signed by Shane Dawson in fact I have
two of them so I can technically say
that Shane Dawson inscribed his name
upon my balls
I'm just want to starting a kitty what
are you doing what are you doing kitty
oh you're such a pest oh look at that
fuzzy foot fuzzy foot kiddie accordion I
played this game it's got Kitty
accordion
she's an accordion it's not torture if
she's not running away if she didn't
like it she'd run away I have been very
impressed by everyone's amazing VidCon
recap videos thank you to everyone who's
making those I'm gonna put a link to a
few of my favorites down the doobly-doo
but John there are things in the world
and this may surprise you that are not
VidCon as you undoubtedly know BP has
managed after all these months to put a
cap on the
broken well the bottom of the Gulf of
Mexico this will actually mark an end to
the outpouring of millions of gallons of
oil into the Gulf of Mexico at least
until it happens again
speaking of horrible things John and I
both neglected to make a video last week
and many people have been saying oh but
guys we totally forgive you because you
were working so hard on VidCon that is
not how this works friends we made an
agreement brother to brother nerdfighter
to nerdfighter that we would make videos
on schedule and we failed and thus we
both must be punished I have activated
the YouTube moderator module below this
video on the vlogbrothers channel
youtube.com slash vlogbrothers please go
there you can suggest punishments or you
can vote on punishments that have
already been suggested now we can't
guarantee that we'll take the number one
most voted punishment but we can
guarantee that it will be something
unpleasant remember the best punishments
are embarrassing but not illegal and
painful but not dangerous seriously
thank you to everyone who has supported
VidCon whether you were there or not
people keep telling me that it was a
huge gigantic success but really I think
that what we had was low expectations
and really really amazing people as part
of this community and without those
things everyone would have just laughed
at how silly the whole thing was but
instead it became what I think is a
really really important thing so thanks
everyone for that thanks for being a
part of this community and John I will
see you on Friday